so now this time you're going to have to
help me because I don't get to look at
both page at the same time you've got
the coordinates in front of you I'm
going to turn to my page here and I've
written all of this in pen now i'm going
to pick up a pencil okay so i'm gonna do
this next bit in pencil and if you've
got a pencil you should do it same can
someone tell me whatever what's the
first coordinates that you've got the
first one you're hannah negative 42 very
good so negative 4 tells me to go four
units to the left and two units up very
good so I count across to here I've
drawn a big fat diet and I'm gonna label
what it is as well negative 4 comma 2
all right I've done my first one four
more to go negative two comma 0 where's
that yeah yeah yeah that's it isn't it
the zero means you don't have to go up
and down so that is where negative two
comma 0 is right and you can do the rest
of them 1 comma negative 3 actually i'll
give you can i give you like half a
minute just finish off the last week
winter then i will draw them in you can
check if you've got the right okay go
ahead and draw them okay you can look up
now so this is what your completed
cartesian plane should look like that's
where all the points are now I haven't
told you yet to join them up I'm going
to ask you to join them up now in a
particular way do you notice you've got
five points there's the first three and
then there's the last two okay can you
try not the first three join them up and
then join up connect the last two and
that's two separate lines can you do
that for me just take a second to do it
which one oh it is too lets her I can be
a bit cheap hmm there we go bless you
okay so I'm gonna join these up now
you'll see this one has a line he goes
through it and this one has a line that
goes through it ok now we're done for
now rear do you have a question 1
negative 3 you're talking about this one
down here is that the one you're talking
about yeah no it's okay that's right
this is why we're doing it right so then
we learned how to do it um who's got a
diagram looks pretty similar to mine
yeah cool all right thinking hands down
so I'm we're done this is what the
question was now from here there might
be a whole bunch of different questions
that get asked you for instance you know
how I asked you to draw two lines two
lines the green ones okay you might get
asked are those lines parallel are they
parallel they're not they're pretty
close aren't they right but eventually
they're going to hit somewhere somewhere
down over here they're going to connect
right later on we'll get to work out how
do you find out where they're connect if
you want you want to try and work it out
you actually can okay but that was all
there was to it okay so come back to
this five steps right read drink draw
label pot and that's it okay